but please please like this is one of
the top tips to be completely honest
because it really really can get you to
a job when
even you may not have been looking for
one hello everybody my name is nyan i'm
the black female engineer i provide
content for new and aspiring software
engineers and today
we're talking about how to get a new
developer job
without having any past experience
so let's get to it number one if you
don't have
any previous experience in you know tech
or development
it's okay to now lean into your projects
lean into your projects and let those
projects actually
take up the space of where the previous
experience
would on your resume this is what i did
because i did not have any
previous tech experience and so i really
leaned in on the full stack
web applications i had built these could
be projects from your boot camp if you
go to a boot camp
ozark you will be building and
developing projects it can be projects
from there
it can be projects from out of boot camp
or some other program or no program
at all it really doesn't matter where
it's from
it matters what it is what matters is
the quality of it
so don't get so wrapped up in oh well
this is from
snx program or xnx or whatever
more focus on is this something i would
be proud
to show to an employer now if you're
wondering which type of projects you
should be adding to your portfolio
or to your just list of projects that
you've built i'll add a link below and
above
to the video i made about which projects
you should have
in your portfolio so i'll add those so
don't worry but yes worry about quality
and i'd say
having four to five projects is really
where you want to lean into
especially because you can add different
projects to your resume
to better suit your resume to the type
of employer you're applying for
so if you let's say have built some type
of financial
app that can be something you add to
your resume to tailor to
a bank of america application and so it
just provides some more leeway
and also provides some more leeway in
terms of what you speak about
in your interviews now number two okay
you don't have any previous relevant
experience
but if you do have previous job
be okay to put that in if you believe
you accomplished something
that is relevant to the new
job you're looking to have now and so
for me
i have a background in finance and so i
had worked at bank of america
the previous year before i started
applying to jobs as a developer
and so i included that job but in
the blurbs of descriptions and the
bullet points that i
added you know my day-to-days and
accomplishments and all of that
one of the things i added was that one
day i automated the journal entry
process
and that's something that's relevant to
developer roles
and it's something i was very proud of
because it also
very clearly showed my determination
and my work ethic and so if you have
something that you believe
would provide some better insight into
who you are
as a worker who you would be as a
developer put it on there
just put it on the let's say additional
work experience
part of your resume it's okay to admit
that you haven't been a developer for
the last 20 years
what you should aim for is showing what
type of professional
you are my third tip is to contribute to
open source projects now what's open
source
open source projects are projects that
are available to the public
and are able to be modified and enhanced
by other developers that's really what
it is and by contributing to open source
projects
you get to practice your coding skill
right on real projects and one that's
very exciting but it can also be very
daunting
which is why many people can have a
certain type of hesitation towards this
but the reason this can really assist in
your job hunt is because
one you can add it to your resume the
type of open source projects you
contributed to
and what you did and that would count as
relevant experience
but two you are now working with other
community developers
you're developing those relationships
they are learning about you
how you code and if they like you like
your personality
like you how you work and see that you
are a quick learner
then that can open the door to future
work opportunities
if they have a job opening for their
company
then they can relay that information on
to you because they've
gotten to work with you they haven't
gone to work with the
30 000 applicants that they are
reviewing every single day
they've gone to work with you and so
that gives you
such a leg up in the job hunt process
now contributing to your first
open source project can be very daunting
and scary it can be not super
easy but that is the experience for
everybody please
do not let that deter you from this
route and it's also just
something good to do in general helping
the community out by in
essence donating your time to help with
their software help with their projects
their apps etc
that can also be a very rewarding
experience
job hunt aside i'll provide some more
information below
on open source contributions but please
please like this
is one of the top tips to be completely
honest because it really really
can get you to a job when even
you may not have been looking for one
and my last tip this
can for some people be seen as kind of
bold for me
it would have but it's become so much
more common and that is
asking for referrals join facebook
groups
join linkedin groups join communities
that
are tailored to the dev world and ask
for referrals
and when i i say that because
asking for referrals i don't know how
many people know this but it can be very
much
mutually beneficial because if you ask
somebody to refer you
to their company and then weeks
or months down the line that company
hires you
that person who referred you often i
actually have never really heard of a
situation
where this doesn't happen but they get
some type of benefit from the company
i used to work for a company where they
would pay out
five thousand dollars every time you
sent over
a referral to them and they ended up
hiring that person
5 000
yeah so don't think that this is
something that
someone wouldn't want to do for you or
is just benefiting you
and you feel a certain way asking no it
can be very mutually beneficial and that
person referring you
may be so glad that you asked because
now they have a chance to get five
thousand dollars if you're hired
typically with referrals that person may
need your resume
and maybe a cover letter to accompany it
and so make sure you have those things
set and ready before you ask because
it's quite
upsetting when someone asks you for
something and then they're unprepared so
make sure you're not unprepared
make sure you have everything set in
stone for your resume and kindly and
respectfully
ask if somebody would be willing to
refer you to a company
what might even be great is making a
list
of your top 10 20 30 50 companies
and putting that in the developer
facebook group and saying
can anybody refer me to all of these
companies
and if you don't know what i'm talking
about when i talk about facebook groups
and everything
check out my video how to find a mentor
i say mentor but it's really
a lot very heavily on groups and
facebook groups and linkedin groups
so check that out just because i don't
like to repeat myself between videos so
that
the content can stay unique and fresh
and all of that for you all so that is
that final tip
ask for a referral now keep in mind i
kept a lot of
more general tips out because i do have
multiple videos that
cover how to get a software developer
job especially when it's your first
developer job and so i'll link those
below again i don't
i want to make sure each of my videos
are staying unique which is why
i didn't go into those but i hope
these tips you found something or heard
something that you've never
heard before because that's always the
goal so please let me know what that tip
was if that's the case
please like and subscribe and i'll see
you all later
bye